Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply.
从家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日特惠开始，你的夏天即刻启程。是时候用 Next 烤架四燃烧器燃气烤架开启夏日烧烤了，特惠价仅需 199 美元。整个季节，你都可以用汉普顿湾西格罗夫七件套户外餐桌椅尽情招待亲友，仅需 49 美元。今年阵亡将士纪念日，来家得宝享受超低价格保证。售完即止，价格有效期至 5 月 14 日或 5 月 27 日。仅限美国，部分地区除外。
See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. 2020 was the world's warmest year on record, and 2024 could bring another record-shattering summer. In April, the National Weather Service released an outlook that predicted hotter than average conditions across most of the U.S. this summer. When we think of the consequences of extreme heat, physical dangers may come to mind first, things like heat exhaustion or heat stroke. But psychologists and public health researchers have found that heat can affect our mental health as well as our physical health. So what do those effects look like? How does extreme heat affect our mental health, our emotions, and even our cognitive abilities? What is the link among heat, violence, and aggression?
详情请访问 Home Depot.com/pricematch。2020 年是有记录以来全球最热的一年，而 2024 年可能会迎来另一个打破纪录的酷暑。今年四月，美国国家气象局发布了一份预测报告，预计今年夏天美国大部分地区的平均气温将高于往年。当我们想到极端高温带来的后果时，身体危险可能会最先浮现在脑海，比如中暑衰竭或中暑痉挛。但心理学家和公共卫生研究人员发现，高温不仅会影响我们的身体健康，还会影响我们的心理健康。那么这些影响具体是什么样的呢？极端高温如何影响我们的心理健康、情绪，甚至认知能力？高温、暴力和攻击性之间有什么联系？
Who is most vulnerable to the effects of extreme heat? And what should policymakers and others be doing to mitigate the effects of extreme heat in a world that's only getting hotter? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science. and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. First is Dr. Kim Middenbauer, an assistant professor in the Washington State University Department of Psychology, where she heads the social, cognitive, and environmental neuroscience laboratory. Dr. Maddenbauer's research focuses on how the physical and social environment affects people's brain and behavior. She's particularly interested in the negative effects of heat stress and air pollution, as well as how
谁最容易受到极端高温的影响？在一个越来越热的世界里，政策制定者和其他人应该采取什么措施来减轻极端高温的影响？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。今天我们请到了两位嘉宾。首先是金·米登鲍尔（Kim Meidenbauer）博士，她是华盛顿州立大学心理学系的助理教授，并在那里领导社会、认知和环境神经科学实验室。米登鲍尔博士的研究重点是物理和社会环境如何影响人们的大脑和行为。她对热应激和空气污染的负面影响特别感兴趣，同时
interacting with natural spaces can improve our physical and mental health. Our second guest is Dr. Amruda Norese Sarma, an assistant professor in the Environmental Health Department at the Boston University School of Public Health. She studies the relationship between climate change and health outcomes in vulnerable communities. She has also examined the impact of heat waves and air pollution on health in India, South Korea, and across the U.S. Her current research aims to understand the effects of extreme weather events on mental health. Thank you both for joining me today. Thank you for having us.
与自然空间的互动如何改善我们的身心健康。我们的第二位嘉宾是阿鲁达·努里·萨尔马（Amruta Noori Sarma）博士，她是波士顿大学公共卫生学院环境健康系的助理教授。她研究弱势群体中气候变化与健康结果之间的关系。她还研究了热浪和空气污染对印度、韩国以及全美各地健康的影響。她目前的研究旨在了解极端天气事件对心理健康的影响。非常感谢两位今天做客我的节目。谢谢邀请我们。
Great to be here. Now, you're both interested in heat and mental health, and you both come to it from different backgrounds. Dr. Nouri Sarma, your PhD is in public health. Dr. Madenbauer, you're a psychologist who's interested in how our environments affect us. Can you each tell us a little bit about your background and how you came to study the topic? And maybe Dr. Mindbauer, we'll start with you. Yeah. So my background and kind of my PhD work was focused in environmental psychology, really focused on how interacting with nature benefits us and why.
很高兴来到这里。现在，你们都对高温与心理健康很感兴趣，而且你们都来自不同的背景。努里·萨尔马博士，您的博士学位是在公共卫生领域。米登鲍尔博士，您是一位心理学家，对我们的环境如何影响我们感兴趣。你们能分别介绍一下自己的背景以及你们是如何开始研究这个课题的吗？也许我们可以从米登鲍尔博士开始。好的。所以我的背景和我的博士工作主要集中在环境心理学，真正关注的是与自然互动如何让我们受益以及原因。
And so studying kind of the effects of the physical environment on individuals, I mean, it's hard to not think about heat and the effects of heat stress in the wake of an ever warming planet. And in the context of climate change, I was just increasingly more concerned with, you know, how is heat affecting us? And we know a lot about how nature is good for us. And I was doing a lot of work on why. But it was sort of like, well, we know nature is good for us. We know a lot less about how heat is affecting us psychologically. And it seemed like a natural kind of next step to look at an undoubtedly important one. And Dr. Norisarma, how did you get interested in this topic? So, as you mentioned, my PhD work is really focused on the environmental side. So I'm coming at this from the perspective of environmental epidemiology. And I've always been really interested in leveraging different data resources to try and understand the impacts of climate-related exposures in understudied communities and underserved communities and also on outcomes that we don't really understand as well.
因此，在研究物理环境对个人的影响时，在地球不断变暖的背景下，很难不考虑热量和热应激的影响。在气候变化的背景下，我越来越关心：高温是如何影响我们的？我们对大自然如何对我们有益了解很多，我做了很多关于原因的研究。但这有点像，好吧，我们知道大自然对我们有益。我们对高温如何在心理上影响我们知之甚少。这似乎是审视一个无疑很重要的环节的自然下一步。努里·萨尔马博士，您是怎么对这个话题感兴趣的？正如您所提到的，我的博士工作主要集中在环境方面。所以我这是从环境流行病的角度来研究的。我一直对利用不同的数据资源非常感兴趣，试图了解气候相关暴露在研究不足的社区和资源匮乏的社区中的影响，以及我们真正了解不够的结果。
So it seemed to me like the mental health implications of environmental exposures was a natural next step in progression of my research. We understand relatively a lot more about the physical health impacts of extreme heat, for example, and we understand a lot less about the ways in which extreme heat and other types of climate-related extreme weather events are impacting people's mental health and well-being. Now, Dr. Nori-Sama, you did a study several years ago that found a link. between hot days and mental health-related emergency room visits. Can you talk about this? What did you do? What did you find?
因此在我看来，环境暴露对心理健康的影響是我研究发展的自然下一步。例如，我们对极端高温对身体健康的负面影响了解相对较多，而对极端高温和其他类型的气候相关极端天气事件如何影响人们的心理健康和福祉却知之甚少。现在，努里·萨尔马博士，您几年前做过一项研究，发现了一个联系。炎热日子与心理健康相关的急诊室就诊之间。你能谈谈这个吗？你是怎么做的？你发现了什么？
Absolutely. So the work that we were doing a couple of years ago that you mentioned, which was published in JAMA Psychiatry in 2022, was leveraging data among commercial health insurance beneficiaries. So we looked at all U.S. adults with commercial health insurance through this one particular commercial insurance provider to understand the impact. act of extreme heat or elevated temperatures on mental health outcomes, particularly emergency department visits associated with mental illness. So what we were able to do is between 2010 and 2019 in the summers of each of those years, we were able to look at changes in the rates of
当然。正如您所提到的，我们几年前开展的那项工作于 2022 年发表在《美国医学会杂志·精神病学分册》（JAMA Psychiatry）上，它利用了商业健康保险受益人的数据。因此，我们通过这个特定的商业保险提供商调查了所有拥有商业健康保险的美国成年人，以了解其影响。极端高温或气温升高对心理健康结果的影响，特别是与精神疾病相关的急诊就诊。因此，我们能够做的是在 2010 年至 2019 年期间每个夏天的夏天，我们能够查看
emergency department visits associated with mental health as summertime temperatures were increasing. And additionally, we were able to look at potentially vulnerable groups within commercially insured beneficiary. So we looked at differences by region across the U.S. We also looked at differences between men versus women and differences by different age groups. And what we found in that study is that as summertime temperatures were increasing, we found a direct increase in the rates of emergency department visits, both for any mental health outcome as well as for specific causes. So we looked at, for example, increases in the rates of emergency department visits for substance use disorders, for schizophrenia, for self-harm,
随着夏季气温的升高，与心理健康相关的急诊就诊率增加。此外，我们能够研究商业保险受益人中潜在的脆弱群体。因此，我们研究了美国不同地区的差异。我们还研究了男性与女性之间的差异以及不同年龄组之间的差异。我们在该研究中发现的是，随着夏季气温的升高，急诊就诊率直接上升，无论是针对任何心理健康结果还是针对特定原因。因此，我们研究了例如物质使用障碍、精神分裂症、自残等急诊就诊率的增加，
for mood disorders, for different types of stress and anxiety disorders. And we found increasing rates of emergency department visits for each of these different mental health endpoints, which suggested to me that Extreme Heat is an exogenous stressor that's exacerbating people's underlying mental health symptoms because we found such similar rates of increases in mental health emergencies across very, very different health endpoints. One other thing that I want to highlight, which I thought was an interesting finding from that study, is that we found that people living in higher latitudes, so people in more northern parts of the U.S. had higher rates of emergency department visits as summertime temperatures increased, which was a little bit counterintuitive.
针对心境障碍、不同类型的压力和焦虑症。我们发现所有这些不同的心理健康终点的急诊就诊率都在上升，这向我表明，极端高温是一种外在压力源，正在加剧人们潜在的心理健康症状，因为我们在截然不同的健康终点中发现了如此相似的心理健康急急诊增加率。我想强调的另一件事，我认为这是该研究的一个有趣发现，我们发现生活在较高纬度地区的人们，即美国更北部地区的人们，随着夏季气温的升高，急诊就诊率更高，这有点违反直觉。
You might expect to see higher rates in the southern U.S. where temperatures are higher. So I think that spoke a little bit to community level adaptation. So in the more northern, parts of the U.S., maybe there's not as much air conditioning penetration, maybe people aren't used to these summertime temperatures already. And so as summertime temperatures were increasing, we saw increased need for emergency care in some of those more northern communities. There's also been research that's found a connection between heat waves and higher crime rates. How is heat related to aggression and violence? And what have you and other researchers found out? Dr. Madenbauer? The link between heat and aggression is something that
你可能会期望在气温更高的美国南部看到更高的比率。所以我认为这在一定程度上说明了社区层面的适应。因此在更北部，在美国的部分地区，可能没有那么普及的空调，人们可能还不习惯这些夏季气温。因此，随着夏季气温的升高，我们看到其中一些更北部社区对紧急护理的需求增加。还有研究发现热浪与较高的犯罪率之间存在联系。热量与攻击性和暴力有何关系？您和其他研究人员发现了什么？米登鲍尔博士？热量和攻击性之间的联系是
I mean, people have been saying it for literal decades like Craig Anderson doing some of the kind of early work on it and still doing an excellent work on it. And yeah, it sort of started when people noticed, you know, crime on hot days. There's a real relationship. It was, it's obvious, I think, to people even just anecdotally. I think people notice it. And it kind of generated all these questions about like, well, what's happening and why? And kind of the dominant theories sort of early on were all about, well, maybe it's just bringing more people outside. And when you have more people outside, you have more
我的意思是，人们已经谈论了整整几十年，比如克雷格·安德森（Craig Anderson）做了一些关于它的早期工作，并且仍然在做非常出色的工作。是的，这有点开始于人们注意到，你知道，炎热天气的犯罪。这是一种真正的关系。我认为，即使只是凭经验，这对人们来说也是显而易见的。我想人们注意到了这一点。它引发了所有这些问题，比如，发生了什么，为什么？早期的主要理论都与以下方面有关：也许这只是把更多的人带到了外面。当你有更多的人在外面时，你有更多的
opportunity. So this is the idea of what's called routine activities theory. But then Dr. Anderson comes in and sort of like, well, actually, we also know that he makes people angry, right? It makes them feel uncomfortable. It makes them feel hostile. It maybe even changes our perceptions of other individuals. So you might see others as looking like they're more threatening or hostile to us. And so he and a few other researchers, you know, they did a lot of work looking at, you know, why does heat cause aggression? And kind of one of the main things they really did focus on is the fact that it makes us angry. It affects our social perception. And increasingly, I think there's more of an interest and sort of something I'm starting to tease apart is whether heat's effects on cognition can also be playing a role here because we know cognitive control, like your ability to stop yourself.
机会。这就是所谓的常规活动理论。但随后安德森博士介入并指出，实际上，我们也知道高温会让人生气，对吧？这让他们感到不舒服。这让他们感到敌意。它甚至可能会改变我们对其他个人的看法。因此，你可能会认为其他人看起来对我们更具威胁性或敌意。因此，他和一些其他研究人员做了很多工作来研究，为什么高温会导致攻击性？他们真正关注的主要事情之一就是它让我们生气这一事实。它影响我们的社会知觉。而且我认为，人们越来越感兴趣，我开始着手解决的问题是，高温对认知的负面影响是否也在这里发挥作用，因为我们知道认知控制，比如你阻止自己的能力。
from engaging in aggression, right? Like that is something that matters, and that is also something that's affected by heat. And Dr. Nori Sarma, are these things that you found as well? I mean, is there research that says basically on a hot day? Maybe you're, I don't know, not thinking as clearly as you might on a more temperate day? Yes, I think that that's very plausible. One other biological pathway that I want to mention is sleep disruption. I think that sleep disruption also plays an important role here.
参与攻击行为，对吧？这确实很重要，这也是受热量影响的因素。努里·萨尔马博士，这些也是您发现的事情吗？我的意思是，有没有研究表明基本上在炎热的日子里？也许你，我不知道，没有像在更温和的日子里那样思考得那么清楚？是的，我认为这非常合理。我想提及的另一个生物学途径是睡眠中断。我认为睡眠中断在这里也起着重要的作用。
And we know that especially as summertime extreme heat periods last longer and they're more frequent and they're more severe, the daily maximum temperature is increasing, but also the overnight temperatures are increasing as well. And so I think these patterns of more sustained in duration and more intense heat waves that also afford people less of an opportunity to cool off during the nighttime period can also lead to sleep disruption, which I think is directly relevant to some of these increases in aggression and different behavioral disruptions. that Dr. Middendvara was mentioning as well. Let's talk for a minute about climate equity. We know that some groups of people are more vulnerable to the harms of extreme heat than others. Who is the most vulnerable in both the United States and around the world to extreme heat? Sure. So I think that this is a very complicated question.
我们知道，特别是随着夏季极端热浪期持续时间更长、更频繁、更严重，白天的最高气温在升高，夜间的气温也在升高。因此，我认为这种持续时间更长、强度更大的热浪模式也让人们在夜间降温的机会更少，这也可能导致睡眠中断，我认为这与攻击性增加和不同行为中断直接相关。米登鲍尔博士刚才也提到了这一点。让我们花一分钟讨论一下气候公平。我们知道，某些群体比其他人更容易受到极端高温的危害。在美国和世界各地，谁最容易受到极端高温的影响？当然。所以我觉得这是一个非常复杂的问题。
And I think that vulnerability goes hand in hand with intersectionality. So there might be a lot of different components of individual and community. level factors that convey vulnerability to different populations. The one that we always think about is socioeconomic status, and we know that that's a huge issue for populations in the U.S. and both around the world as well. And I think that plays into two different scenarios. So the first one is that people who have lower socioeconomic means have fewer resources to prepare them to adapt and cope in the face of climate stressors. I think that also socioeconomic status is influenced, both influenced by and also influences your neighborhood level characteristics. So maybe
我认为脆弱性与交叉性齐头并进。因此，个人和社区层面可能会有许多不同的因素，将脆弱性传达给不同的人群。我们总是想到的是社会经济地位，我们知道这是美国以及世界各地人口的一个巨大问题。我认为这涉及到两种不同的情况。首先是，社会经济条件较差的人资源较少，无法让他们做好准备，以适应和应对气候压力源。我认为社会经济地位也受到影响，既受影响也影响你的邻里层面的特征。所以也许
you have, you're living in more of an interior urban environment in a big city where there's an urban heat island. So that inability to regulate your temperature to cool off during the nighttime period is exacerbated if you live in an urban heat island. So I think it's an individual level characteristic as well as a neighborhood level characteristic that conveys vulnerability. But additionally, I think that what we've seen across the U.S. is that access to mental health services is also a problem. So people who don't have access to regular care, preventative treatment, people who don't have access to clinicians. And particularly on the mental health side, this is a problem that's only increasing in scope, independent of exposure to climate hazards. So I think, you know, there are a lot of different factors that convey vulnerability to mental health impacts from extreme heat.
你住在大城市里更内向的城市环境中，那里有城市热岛效应。如果你住在城市热岛中，这种调节体温以在夜间降温的无能就会加剧。所以我认为这是一个个人层面的特征，也是一个传达脆弱性的邻里层面的特征。此外，我认为我们在全美各地看到的是，获得心理健康服务的机会也是一个问题。因此，无法获得常规护理、预防性治疗的人，无法接触临床医生的人。特别是在心理健康方面，这个问题在范围上只会不断扩大，而这与暴露于气候危害无关。所以我想，有很多不同的因素将脆弱性传达给极端高温对心理健康的影响。
Yeah, I couldn't agree more. and the effects of socioeconomic status is also the main thing that comes to my mind too, right? Because the ability to adapt and mitigate both, as you say, on a personal level, right, that can you afford AC if you even have it? Can you afford to pay the electrical bill? It's expensive to, so people that might have it still might just not turn it on due to the expense. If you're living in an area with an urban heat island effect, you're also probably have less green space. Green space cools the area, right?
是的，我非常赞同。社会经济地位的影响也是我脑海中最先想到的主要事情，对吧？因为适应和减轻的能力，正如你所说，在个人层面上，对吧，即使你拥有空调，你也买得起吗？你付得起电费吗？这很贵，所以拥有它的人可能只是因为费用而不会打开它。如果你住在有城市热岛效应的地区，你可能也会拥有较少的绿地。绿地使该地区降温，对吧？
like both of these things are tightly linked with socioeconomic status and in some of my work in Chicago, I've also found this very tight coupling between, you know, urban heat island effect, access to resources for cooling and, you know, being of like lower SES background. And obviously that intersects with things like racialization and marginalization. So I think that kind of the importance of these sort of structural factors in predicting vulnerability is huge. the mental health thing, of course, as Dr. Norris-Sarma says, is obviously a major part of it. The other thing that I think about, and I've sort of increasingly started looking at more, is the sort of individual differences actually at a personality level. So, I mean, individual differences
这两者都与社会经济地位紧密相连，在我对芝加哥的一些研究中，我也发现城市热岛效应、获取冷却资源的渠道以及具有较低 SES 背景之间存在这种紧密的联系。显然，这与种族化和边缘化等事情相交织。所以我认为这些结构性因素在预测脆弱性方面的重要性是巨大的。当然，正如努里·萨尔马博士所说，心理健康问题显然是其中的一个主要部分。我认为的另一件事，也是我越来越开始关注的，其实是人格层面的个体差异。所以，也就是个体差异
are when it comes to things like thermal comfort or just your likelihood of experiencing negative emotions, both of those things seem to matter a lot. So people vary a lot in what they perceive as uncomfortable, people vary a lot in, you know, are they likely to experience negative emotions, period? And so some of my recent work has been looking at the effects of personality traits like neuroticism, which, you know, people that are higher on neuroticism, they're more likely to experience negative affect. We also have some data to suggest that they are more affected by uncomfortable heat than people that are lower on neuroticism. So this is some work that my PhD student has been looking into and following up on.
当涉及到热舒适度或经历消极情绪的可能性时，这两者似乎都很重要。因此，人们对他们认为是不可接受的东西的看法差异很大，人们在以下方面也有很大差异：他们是否可能经历消极情绪，句号？因此我最近的一些工作一直在研究人格特质（如神经质）的影响，你知道，神经质得分较高的人更有可能经历消极情感。我们还有一些数据表明，与神经质得分较低的人相比，他们更容易受到不舒服的热量的影响。所以这是我的一名博士生一直在研究和跟进的一些工作。
And so thinking about, you know, heat that's not necessarily like dangerous physically, but just might be uncomfortable and how even just heat that's a little uncomfortable, if you're prone towards negative emotions, if you're prone towards feeling uncomfortable in the heat, like those could have very real psychological consequences, even if you're not in, you know, a level of heat that is physically harmful or dangerous biologically, you know, just even feeling that discomfort could make someone who is higher on neuroticism or, you know, more uncomfortable, more likely to experience the mental health issues. Are there differences based on other factors such as sex, for example, how do men and women
因此，考虑一下，不一定在物理上危险的热量，但可能只是不舒服，以及即使是一点点不舒服的热量，如果你倾向于负面情绪，如果你倾向于在炎热中感到不舒服，这些可能会产生非常真实的心理后果，即使你没有处于生物学上对身体有害或危险的热量水平，你知道，仅仅感受到这种不适就可能让神经质得分较高的人或感到更不舒服的人更容易经历心理健康问题。是否存在基于其他因素的差异，例如性别，男性和女性如何
react differently to heat? I mean, and I think we know older people can be more susceptible to heat problems. So what about children? Yeah, children definitely are like kind of either extreme is where you see the differences and it's in part due to just individual differences in thermal regulation ability, right? Like older adults and younger children, their thermoregulation efficiency is just not where it is with kind of middle adulthood, basically. The gender question is interesting. I have, it's really mixed.
对热的反应不同？我的意思是，我想我们都知道老年人更容易受到高温问题的影响。那么儿童呢？是的，儿童绝对是这样的，无论哪种极端情况你都会看到差异，这部分原因在于个体体温调节能力的差异，对吧？就像老年人和较小的儿童，他们的体温调节效率基本上就是比不上处于中年时期的人。性别问题很有趣。我发现，情况真的很混杂。
I found a lot of really mixed evidence word. I found in some of my data, no effect. Some researchers seem to find it, I don't know. Dr. Norris-Harmah, if you've encountered this, but I think the gender question is, it's a bit of a mess. I haven't made heads or tails of it from the literature or my own data. Yeah, I think that that's the same messaging that we're seeing, the relationship between extreme heat and mental health outcomes between men and women. We see really different results depending on the work that's being done. And one other thing that I want to mention, just going back
我发现了很多非常混杂的证据。我在自己的一些数据中没有发现影响。有些研究人员似乎发现了，我不知道诺里斯-哈马（Norris-Harmah）博士你是否遇到过这种情况，但我认为性别问题有点乱。从文献或我自己的数据中，我都没能理出个头绪。是的，我认为我们看到的也是同样的信息，即男性和女性之间极端高温与心理健康结果之间的关系。根据正在进行的研究，我们看到了截然不同的结果。还有一件事我想提一下，回到
to the age-related differences, I think one of the new areas of research thought I've been really interested in and following closely that I haven't really worked in myself is the relationship between extreme heat and other environmental risk factors and neurological disorders, which I think is maybe a separate category, but kind of belongs within this world. So the impact on Alzheimer's disease and related dementias is really interesting. And there's a couple of different components of that. So there's the stress that is conveyed to the patient. There's also caregiver stress that happens in those scenarios. So I think elderly patients, particularly for a different set of mental health related and well-being-related outcomes that I think are very much associated with this question
与年龄相关的差异，我认为我一直很感兴趣并密切关注的新研究领域之一——虽然我自己并没有真正涉足——是极端高温与其他环境风险因素及神经系统疾病之间的关系，我认为这可能是一个独立的类别，但某种程度上属于这个范畴。因此，它对阿尔茨海默病及相关痴呆症的影响非常有趣。这其中有几个不同的组成部分。首先是对患者产生的压力。在这些情况下，还会产生照顾者的压力。所以，我认为老年患者，特别是对于一组不同的心理健康和福祉相关结果——我认为这些结果在很大程度上与这个问题相关
is an up-and-coming area of research that I think deserves more investigation as well. I totally agree. And it's also interesting to think about the relationship between, like, well-being and resilience and how that might lead to Alzheimer's and related dimensions, right? Like there's a link between those two and there's a link. between heat and cognition. And so I'm actually starting to do some work looking at this and looking at heat-related impairments in cognition in older adults. And does that predict, you know, neurocognitive decline?
这是一个新兴的研究领域，我认为同样值得进行更多的研究。我完全同意。同时，思考福祉与韧性之间的关系，以及这如何可能导致阿尔茨海默病及相关痴呆症，也是很有趣的，对吧？这两者之间存在联系，并且热量与认知之间也存在联系。因此，我实际上开始做一些研究来探讨这个问题，观察老年人中与热相关的认知障碍。这是否能预测（你知道的）神经认知衰退？
So I agree. I think it's a really interesting and kind of important step forward and understanding kind of the scope of some of these effects in the more vulnerable populations like older adults. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost.
所以我同意。我认为这是一个非常有趣且相当重要的新进展，有助于理解某些这类影响在老年人等更易受影响人群中的范围。你刚才说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那些台阶罢了。我们省了多少钱？够了。够去远走高飞了。
Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton for the stay.
或者你也可以在希尔顿预订房间。欢迎来到您的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿特惠活动正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿App上预订，最高可省20%，享受您期望中的住宿体验。当您想要省钱，而不是惊吓时。您住在哪里很重要。希尔顿，每一次入住。
Maybe a little bit of an unfair question because you're not economists, But is there a relationship between heat and productivity? I'm just wondering because people who live in warmer climates, we have the sense that, well, they're all basking on the beach all day. And the people who live in more temperate places, well, they go to work because there's no beach. It's too cold to go to the beach. Am I just making this up or is there some correlation here? I think there's definitely a correlation here.
也许这是一个有点不公平的问题，因为你们不是经济学家，但热量与生产力之间存在关系吗？我只是好奇，因为生活在较温暖气候中的人们，我们的感觉是，好吧，他们整天都在海滩上晒太阳。而生活在较温和地方的人们，嗯，他们去上班，因为没有海滩。太冷了，不能去海滩。我是胡思乱想，还是这里面确实有什么相关性？我认为这里面绝对存在相关性。
And I think this is something that we're starting to see more and more, particularly in highly occupationally exposed environments where the background exposure to extreme heat is already quite high. Climate change is exacerbating these risk factors. The areas that I think come to mind specifically are outdoor workers, such as agricultural workers, people in construction industries. These are all areas where occupational exposures are just going to be elevated as a result of summertime extreme heat. And it leads to a lot of loss of productivity. And I think one of the things that's really important is to consider worker well-being and worker health in the face of different summertime extreme temperatures. And I don't know that there's any standard related to extreme
而且我认为这是我们越来越开始看到的一种现象，特别是在高度职业暴露的环境中，背景中对极端高温的暴露本就已经相当高。气候变化正在加剧这些风险因素。我认为具体浮现在脑海中的群体是户外工作者，例如农业工人、建筑行业人员。在这些领域，由于夏季极端高温，职业暴露只会不断上升。这导致了大量的生产力损失。而且我认为非常重要的一点是，在夏季极端温度面前，要考虑工人的福祉和健康。而且我不知道是否存在与极端情况相关的任何标准
heat exposure in the workplace, which I think can serve to exacerbate people's vulnerability in these highly occupational-exposed settings. Now, many of us have heard about seasonal effective disorder, which is a seasonal mood problem that's mostly associated with winter and light. But what about heat and summer-related mood issues? Are there such things? Summer sad is a thing, and it's so understudied. I'm not in this space, so I won't speak much on it, but I do know it's very much a thing, and our understanding of it appears to be pretty poor at this point. I don't know if Dr. Norisarma has, knows more about it than I do. Honestly, I don't know that I know more about the biological mechanism, but one thing that I can say is that
工作场所的热暴露，我认为这可能会加剧人们在这些高度职业暴露环境中的脆弱性。现在，我们很多人都听说过季节性情感障碍，这是一种主要与冬季和光照有关的季节性情绪问题。但是热量和夏季相关的情绪问题呢？有这种事吗？夏季抑郁是真实存在的，而且受到的研究太少了。我不在这个领域，所以我就不多说了，但我确实知道它是真实存在的，而且目前我们对它的理解似乎相当匮乏。我不知道诺里斯哈马（Norrisarma）博士是否比我知道得更多。老实说，我不知道我是否更了解生物学机制，但我能说的一点是，
when we look at year-round mental illness, emergency department visits associated with mental health, when we look at the year-round trends, we actually don't see increases in the rates of emergency department visits for mental health outcomes among commercially insured individuals during wintertime periods. There's a pretty straightforward increase as temperatures are increasing. So maybe there's something subclinical that's happening with seasonal effective disorder, whereas the presentation during the summertime is just more severe. So more people are presenting to emergency departments in the summer for their summer sad, as Dr. Midinbarar said.
当我们观察全年心理疾病、与心理健康相关的急诊科就诊情况时，当我们观察全年的趋势时，我们实际上并未发现在冬季商业保险个人的心理健康相关急诊就诊率有所增加。随着气温升高，急诊率出现了相当直接的增长。所以也许季节性情感障碍发生了一些亚临床层面的变化，而夏季的表现只是更严重。因此，正如梅登巴尔（Midinbarar）博士所说，夏季因夏季抑郁前往急诊科的人更多了。
But I think maybe there is something very severe that's happening during the summertime periods that we're just not seeing evidence of the same effect in the winter. Dr. Norisarma, I know that because of the work that you've done, you've talked about how psychotropic medications are affected, right? So is it possible that, you know, with your work on the emergency department visits, you know, you're seeing kind of the extreme cases, the subclinical sad, like stereotypical winter sad, right? Does cold affect psychotropic medications? And maybe that's or not affect them. And maybe that's part of the puzzle here. I'm curious what you think. I think that the mechanism for psychotropic medications is really thermal dysregulation that happens with extreme heat.
但我认为也许在夏季确实发生了一些非常严重的事情，而我们在冬季只是没有看到相同影响的证据。诺里斯哈马博士，我知道因为你所做的工作，你曾谈到过精神药物是如何受到影响的，对吧？所以，有没有可能，你知道的，通过你在急诊科就诊方面的研究，你知道的，你看到了极端案例，即亚临床的抑郁，就像典型的冬季抑郁一样，对吧？寒冷会影响精神药物吗？也许这就是或不影响它们。也许这就是其中谜题的一部分。我很好奇你的看法。我认为精神药物的机制实际上是极端高温下发生的体温失调。
So that's why sometimes in the summertime when you see patients who are men's, ill, they'll be bundling up with more and more clothing. And I think I haven't seen any evidence of the linkage between psychotropic drugs and extreme cold exposures. I think it really is a lack of ability to regulate your body's core temperature during extreme heat periods. But I think that likely what we're seeing in the emergency department visits is that a lot of the need for care or the people's experience of their symptoms during the winter is really just thought. So it's hard to capture. There are going to be a lot of people who will be interacting with the health care system that we're not capturing in things like emergency department visit claims or even if we
这就是为什么有时在夏天，当你看到重病患者时，他们会穿越来越多的衣服。而且我认为我没有看到精神药物与极端寒冷暴露之间存在联系的证据。我认为这确实是在极端高温时期缺乏调节身体核心温度的能力。但我认为，我们在急诊科就诊中看到的情况很可能是，冬季期间很多医疗需求或人们对症状的体验其实只是被掩盖了。所以很难捕捉到。会有很多人与医疗系统产生互动，而我们并未在诸如急诊科就诊理赔之类的事情中捕捉到，甚至如果我们
looked at preventative care, even if we looked at, you know, visits to your regular mental health professional. I think those would still fail to capture some of the subclinical outcomes that we might be really concerned about as a result of ongoing climate anxiety or other types of regular stressors from our environment. What about the impact of heat on people who are taking other kinds of medications? For example, if you're on blood thinners or you're on medication for blood pressure, does heat affect that? I don't know that heat affects, I don't know the effects by medication status, but I do know that heat definitely has adverse impacts on patients who have chronic illnesses. So we do see a lot of evidence of increased cardiovascular disease risk and increases in another
审视预防性保健，甚至如果我们审视（你知道的）去看你的常规心理健康专业人员。我认为这些仍然无法捕捉到一些亚临床结果，由于持续的气候焦虑或我们环境中其他类型的常规压力源，我们可能会对此非常关切。热量对服用其他类型药物的人有什么影响？例如，如果你在服用血液稀释剂或高血压药物，热量会对此产生影响吗？我不知道热量是否会产生影响，我不知道按药物状态划分的影响，但我确实知道热量对患有慢性病的患者肯定有不利影响。因此，我们确实看到很多证据表明心血管疾病风险增加，以及在另一个
area that I think has been really interesting is cardiometabolic outcomes. So patients with diabetes who need insulin or require insulin have been particularly distressed during periods of extreme heat. So this is also an area that I think needs more research, but there is evidence of increased impacts on physical and mental health among patients with chronic illnesses as summertime temperatures are increasing. What about the other side of the coin? Can heat be beneficial to physical and mental health? I think that's a really interesting question. I mean, I will say that there's some research that looks at like using saunas for health benefits, right? It's a very different type of heat
我认为非常有趣的领域是心脏代谢结果。需要胰岛素的糖尿病患者在极端高温期间尤其感到痛苦。因此，这也是一个我认为需要更多研究的领域，但随着夏季气温的升高，确实有证据表明它对慢性病患者的身心健康有更大的影响。硬币的另一面呢？热量会对身心健康有益吗？我认为这是一个非常有趣的问题。我的意思是，我要说的是有些研究着眼于像利用桑拿来获得健康益处，对吧？这是一种非常不同类型的热
exposure, right? But, like, there is some work looking at, you know, acute heat exposure under, like, you know, a medical professional or someone who's there to protect the patients and, you know, kind of actually boosting your thermoregulation ability through kind of repeated heat exposure because we know that adaptation is a thing. So I think the idea of kind of acute, safely administered short-term heat exposure, to protect against both later heat and just kind of some other things like I've heard. So because there's a relationship between like core temperature and depression, I've heard some arguments for like if you use saunas, get people to thermoregulate better, maybe this can actually address some of the depressive symptoms, which again, a little understudied, hard to know really what's going on there biologically. But I think it's a really interesting idea. And so I think kind of like acute heat exposure through sauna or infrared light or
暴露，对吧？但是，确实有一些研究探讨在医学专业人员或保护患者的人在场的情况下进行急性热暴露，（你知道的）通过反复的热暴露实际上提升你的体温调节能力，因为我们知道适应是存在的。所以我认为这种急性、安全实施的短期热暴露的想法，既能抵御后期的热量，又能抵御其他一些事情，就像我听说的那样。因为核心温度与抑郁之间存在关系，我听到过一些论点，比如如果你使用桑拿，让人体温调节得更好，也许这实际上可以解决一些抑郁症状，这同样研究较少，很难真正了解生物学上发生了什么。但我认为这是一个非常有趣的想法。因此，我认为通过桑拿或红外光进行急性热暴露或
something like that is a really interesting idea. I don't know about like exposure to heat in summer in general. It seems to be like some people like it more, but I don't know if it's necessarily good for them. Yeah. I think that the important point that Dr. Meidenbauer brings up, which I want to underscore here, is that I think there's a meaningful difference between acute exposure to very short periods of intense temperatures versus a general change in your chronic exposure to extreme heat. And a lot of evidence in places of the world that are already experiencing more extreme and longer lasting and frequent heat waves has shown that there are thresholds beyond which our body just loses the capacity to cope with extreme heat exposure.
类似这样的事情是一个非常有趣的想法。我不知道一般夏天接触热量的情况。似乎有些人更喜欢它，但我不知道它是否真的对他们有好处。是的。我认为梅登巴尔博士提出的一个重要观点，我想在这里强调的是，我认为对极高温度进行非常短期的急性暴露与普遍改变你长期暴露于极端高温之间存在有意义的区别。世界上已经经历更极端、更持久、更频繁热浪的许多地方的大量证据表明，存在一些阈值，超过这些阈值，我们的身体就会失去应对极端热暴露的能力。
So I think even, you know, even if we're thinking about it in terms of what is the ideal temperature for humans to thrive, there is a temperature beyond which we just kind of start to lose that ability to adapt and to cope and be resilient. in the face of these environmental stressors. And so I think there's maybe potentially two different discussions to be had there. One is acute heat as potentially restorative and curative for mental health and well-being. But then there's the separate conversation of our more chronic exposure to heat extremes, which I think is a separate risk factor.
所以我想即使（你知道的）即使我们从人类茁壮成长所需要的理想温度的角度来考虑，也存在一个温度，超过这个温度，我们就会开始失去适应、应对以及在这些环境压力源面前保持韧性的能力。因此，我认为这里可能有两个不同的讨论。一个是急性热作为对心理健康和福祉具有恢复和治疗作用。但随后还有另一个单独的讨论，即我们对极端热量的更长期暴露，我认为这是一个独立的风险因素。
So what's that level where we lose it? I mean, you know, we're seeing the ambient temperature, the average temperature around the world going up. Are we getting close in some places where they're regularly hitting 120 degrees Fahrenheit during the summer? Is that close to the threshold? Yeah, and I think that this is part of the broader conversation around the global climate changes that we're seeing. You know, if we talk about the thresholds that have been declared by our international conventions, some people talk about one and a half degree centigrade of overall warming. Some people talk about two degrees centigrade of overall warming.
那么我们失去这种能力的临界点在哪里呢？我的意思是，（你知道的）我们看到世界各地的环境温度、平均温度都在上升。在某些地方，夏天经常达到120华氏度，我们是否正在接近这个临界点？是的，我认为这是围绕我们所看到的全球气候变化的更广泛讨论的一部分。你知道的，如果我们谈论由国际会议宣布的阈值，有些人谈论整体变暖1.5摄氏度。有些人谈论整体变暖2摄氏度。
But the thing that I think we need to keep in mind is that there are some places. in the world where they've already hit those thresholds and they've consistently seen those systemic increases in our summertime ambient temperatures across the course of the last few summers. And these are places that will already experience additional weeks of extreme heat. We've seen it across South Asia in the last couple of weeks since the beginning of the 24 summertime heat period. We're starting to see evidence of this in Europe. I think we're going to experience this overall change in our exposure to extreme heat in a variety of different contexts globally.
但我认为我们需要记住的事情是，世界上有一些地方已经达到了这些阈值，并且在过去几个夏天的过程中，持续看到了我们夏季环境温度的系统性上升。这些地方已经经历额外几周的极端高温。我们在过去几周里，自24年夏季高温期开始以来，在南亚看到了这种情况。我们开始在欧洲看到这种证据。我认为我们将在全球各种不同的背景下经历这种整体对极端高温暴露的变化。
Well, let's try for a moment to talk about possible solutions. Do you have thoughts about what policymakers, governments can do to kind of mitigate the mental health and physical health effects of extreme heat? Yeah, I mean, I think it's a really complex problem and it's going to require approaching it from a lot of different angles. I mean, for me, again, as someone who's done a lot of research before on the benefits of nature exposure, like the first thing that comes to my mind is green space infrastructure as something that can both reduce the heat, especially in urban heat island affected areas. But also, you know, exposure to nature has its own mental health benefits, right? We see that spending time or even just having more tree canopy in your neighborhood has mental health.
好吧，让我们试着花一点时间讨论可能的解决方案。对于决策者、政府可以做些什么来减轻极端高温对心理健康和身体健康的影响，你有什么想法吗？是的，我的意思是，我认为这是一个非常复杂的问题，需要从许多不同的角度来解决它。我的意思是，对我来说，作为之前对接触自然的好处做过大量研究的人，我脑海中浮现的第一件事就是绿地基础设施，它既能减少热量，特别是在受城市热岛影响的区域。而且，接触自然本身也有心理健康的好处，对吧？我们看到花时间甚至只是在你的社区里有更多的树冠都能带来心理健康。
and can reduce a lot of other behaviors that we care about. Like, it can reduce aggression. It can improve cognition. So I like to think of green space infrastructure as kind of like a one-two punch for addressing some of these issues, you know, reducing temperatures, potentially mitigating against global warming and climate change effects and then cleaning the air and, you know, having these sort of mental health benefits directly. but at the same time, there's an argument that, well, even if you planted all the trees
并且可以减少许多我们关心的其他行为。比如，它可以减少攻击性。它可以改善认知。所以我喜欢把绿地基础设施看作是解决其中一些问题的一石二鸟之策，（你知道的）降低温度，可能减轻全球变暖和气候变化的影响，然后净化空气，（你知道的）直接带来这些心理健康好处。但与此同时，有一种观点认为，好吧，即使你种了所有的树
and the urban heat island disappeared in an area, you're still going to have really hot days. And if people don't have ways to cool themselves, like, that's still going to be a problem. So it's tricky because I don't want to be like, we should install air conditioning everywhere because that actually makes the, that also has negative effects on climate change. So it's like such a, but at the same time, for really vulnerable populations, it's like, what do you do, right? You don't want to put people at risk on really, really hot days. So I don't know, it's complicated. It's hard. Yeah, no, I think that the ones that you've listed are really important. And I think that hand in hand with this conversation around nature-based solutions,
即使某个地区的城市热岛效应消失了，仍然会有非常炎热的日子。如果人们没有降温的方法，那仍然会是一个问题。所以这很棘手，因为我不想说我们应该到处安装空调，因为这实际上会产生负面影响，对气候变化也有负面影响。所以这就像是一个……但与此同时，对于真正脆弱的人群，你会觉得该怎么办呢？你不会希望在非常非常炎热的日子里把人们置于危险之中。所以我不知道，这很复杂。这很难。是的，不，我认为你们列出的这些真的很重要。而且我认为，与这种基于自然的解决方案的讨论齐头并进的是，
I think there's a conversation to be had around accessibility of those solutions. I think that one of the communities that is very vulnerable that often gets left out of the discussion. is the disability community, people with other existing disabilities that may also intersect with their vulnerability to extreme heat. And so accessibility to nature-based solutions is really important. And I think it's important to keep in mind that different communities may have differential access to those solutions. So making it as equitable as possible is really important. The other component of that that I think plays into vulnerability is that there's a new concept of, so everyone has probably heard of gentrification. There's a new concept.
我认为还有一个关于这些解决方案可及性的讨论。我认为，一个非常脆弱且经常被排除在讨论之外的群体，就是残疾人群体，他们患有其他现有残疾，这些残疾也可能与他们对极端高温的脆弱性交织在一起。因此，对基于自然的解决方案的可及性真的非常重要。我认为必须记住，不同的群体可能对这些解决方案具有不同的获取权限。因此，使其尽可能公平非常重要。我认为导致脆弱性的另一个组成部分是，有一个新概念，所以每个人可能都听说过绅士化。有一个新概念。
of climate gentrification where greening neighborhoods and making built environment more sustainable can often price the most vulnerable communities out of their native place or out of the place where they've been living up until now. So I think making sure that in the process of implementing these solutions, we're also improving accessibility and equity in the implementation of these solutions so that the most vulnerable folks still have access to these more cool and safe environments and better physical health, better mental health in these urban communities and worldwide as well as across the U.S. The other thing that I think is really important, that has been a factor in a lot of the different interventions that I've seen around the U.S.
气候绅士化，即绿化社区和使建筑环境更具可持续性，往往会将最脆弱的群体排挤出他们的原生家园，或者他们迄今为止一直生活的地方。因此，我认为必须确保在实施这些解决方案的过程中，我们也在改进这些解决方案实施过程中的可及性和公平性，以便最脆弱的人们仍然能够获得这些更凉爽、更安全的环境，并在这些城市社区以及全美乃至全球获得更好的身体健康和心理健康。我认为非常重要的另一件事是，这已经成为我在全美看到的许多不同干预措施中的一个因素，
is access to public spaces that have cooling. So instead of implementing air conditioning within homes, providing access to publicly available air conditioned spaces in different communities. And for example, here in Boston, the cooling centers in the summer are also warming centers in the winter. So providing access to a safe and warmed space in the wintertime storms. Boston is a cold city. So that's really where those interventions started. And now they've been implemented also as cooling centers. And so one of the things that I think is another area of work is I don't know that we have a good understanding of who's actually using those solutions and how we can make sure that those solutions are targeted towards the most vulnerable.
就是获得有降温设施的公共空间。也就是说，不是在家庭内部安装空调，而是为不同社区提供获得公共可用空调空间的机会。例如，在波士顿，夏天的冷却中心在冬天也是取暖中心。因此，在冬天的风暴中提供安全和温暖的空间。波士顿是一个寒冷的城市。所以这正是这些干预措施开始的地方。现在它们也被作为冷却中心实施。因此，我认为另一个工作领域是我们并不真正清楚谁在实际使用这些解决方案，以及我们如何确保这些解决方案针对最脆弱的人群。
So I think that's also an area that needs to be studied a little bit more, but potentially has really big implications for the effectiveness of interventions to reduce the harmful effects of heat exposure and other types of exposures. Yeah, totally. And I might add on to that that like obviously then also SES intersects with whether or not you can easily get to one of those cooling centers too, right? So I mean, exactly what you said about the green gentrification, right? And kind of the role of. affordability. Like, that's huge. But then I'm thinking personally, we had a, we had a heat wave here in Pullman, Washington last summer at like the very start of the school year. And most places here do not have AC because we've not usually had this as an issue. And, you know, I saw, I like shared with some of my students like, hey, the library is one of those spaces that is, you know, it's always cool. It's open late. But I was like, you know, at the same time, not everyone has a car getting to the library.
因此，我认为这也是一个需要更多研究的领域，但它可能对减少热暴露和其他类型暴露的有害影响的干预措施的有效性产生非常大的影响。是的，完全同意。我还可以补充一点，显然社会经济地位（SES）也与你是否能轻松到达其中一个冷却中心交织在一起，对吧？所以我的意思是，就像你刚才说的关于绿色绅士化一样，对吧？以及可负担性的作用。这太重要了。但接着我在想，去年夏天我们这里，华盛顿州普尔曼市，在学年刚开始的时候就经历了一次热浪。这里大多数地方都没有空调，因为我们以前通常不把这当作一个问题。而且，你知道，我看到，我和我的一些学生分享说，嘿，图书馆就是那种空间，你知道，它总是很凉爽。它关门很晚。但我想，你知道，与此同时，并不是每个人都有车去图书馆。
Like, do you want to get on a hot bus? Do you want to walk in 110 degrees, right? Thinking about just the accessibility of these cooling centers, because I do think they have a huge role in protecting vulnerable populations, but also having enough of them and having them close by where people aren't exposing themselves further to get to them, I think is another kind of tricky piece of the puzzle. Yeah. And the puzzle gets even trickier as you start to look more broadly, not just limiting to the United States, but looking at other populations and other countries worldwide. So, for example, this concept of a cooling center is very relevant in a relatively higher income country like in the U.S. or in Europe.
比如，你想坐一辆热烘烘的公交车吗？你想在110华氏度的高温下步行吗？对吧？仅仅思考这些冷却中心的可及性，因为我确实认为它们在保护弱势群体方面发挥着巨大作用，但拥有足够数量的冷却中心并且让它们足够近，使人们不用为了到达那里而进一步暴露自己，我认为这是另一个棘手的拼图。是的。随着你开始更广泛地看待这个问题，不仅仅局限于美国，而是放眼全球其他群体和国家，这块拼图变得更加棘手。例如，冷却中心这个概念在像美国或欧洲这样相对高收入的国家非常相关。
But I've done a lot of work, for example, in India looking at interventions and development of heat adaptation plans and strategies. And the concept of a cooling center just doesn't really translate in that community because, the most vulnerable populations don't have, you know, the money to pay for a movie theater ticket so that they could go into an air-condition space, for example. So in the development of different adaptation strategies for different communities and different contexts, instead of conceptualizing a building that is a public space with air conditioning, you might conceptualize a public park that stays open for longer hours and provides a green, cool space within a city center so that people have access to cooling, it just looks a little bit different. Or another, for example,
但我做了很多工作，例如在印度研究干预措施以及高温适应计划和策略的发展。冷却中心的这个概念在这个社群里根本行不通，因为最脆弱的群体没有钱买一张电影院的票，这样他们就可以去一个有空调的空间，例如。因此，在为不同的社群和不同的背景制定不同的适应策略时，我们可能不会去构思一个带有空调的公共空间建筑，而是可能会构思一个在市中心开放更长时间并提供绿色、凉爽空间的公共公园，以便人们能够获得降温，它只是看起来有点不同。或者另一个例子，
another strategy was at public transportation centers, drinking water, cold drinking water was provided on the hottest days. Turns out that that had really important benefits for different communities that were in transit in those spaces. So I think, you know, the talk about complicating the matter, it increases as you start to increase the scale of what you're thinking about in terms of solutions. So just to wrap up, what are the next big questions that you would like to see answered, whether it's stuff you're working on or in, you know, in an ideal world, what would we be studying to further the issues that you're looking at? Dr. Madenbauer, you want to start with that one? Sure, yeah. So a lot of kind of what I am doing right now is, is really focusing on
另一个策略是在公共交通枢纽，在最热的日子提供饮用水、冷饮水。事实证明，这对于在这些空间中处于转乘状态的不同群体具有非常重要的好处。所以我想，关于使事情变得复杂，当你开始扩大你对解决方案的思考规模时，这种复杂性就会增加。总而言之，你希望看到解答的下一个重大问题是什么，无论是你正在研究的内容，还是在理想世界中，为了推进你所关注的问题，我们应该研究什么？马登鲍尔博士，你想从这个开始吗？当然，可以。所以，我目前正在做的大部分工作是，真正专注于
those sort of not super, super extreme temperatures because, you know, as we have climatitude, we have more of these extreme weather events, but we also just have an increased warming overall. And one of the things that I'm trying to start looking at is, you know, like, what are just the effects of being, like, uncomfortable? Not necessarily, again, at risk or dangerous, but just feeling uncomfortable. Like, what are the consequences of that? What are who's vulnerable? What are, what, like, at what scale do we need to have a temperature increase for this to show up? And then also, again, the effects of just uncomfortable temperatures on cognition, again, not dangerous. But if you're focusing on how awful you feel because you're like, oh, I hate the heat, it's so hot,
那些不是超级、超级极端的温度，因为，你知道，随着我们有气候趋同，我们有更多这样的极端天气事件，但我们也有整体变暖加剧的情况。我开始尝试研究的事情之一是，你知道，仅仅是感到不舒服会有什么影响？不一定，再次强调，处于危险或危险中，而只是感到不舒服。这会带来什么后果？谁是脆弱的？我们到底需要温度升高到什么规模才会显现出这一点？然后还有，仅仅是不舒服的温度对认知的负面影响，同样，不是危险的。但是如果你专注于你因为觉得自己状态糟糕而感到多么难受，因为你觉得，哦，我讨厌热，天气太热了，
I'm so comfortable. You know, that's like a cognitive load in and of itself. It's a distractor. And so a lot of what I'm kind of turning my research tube is looking at this sort of like less extreme change in temperature, but, you know, noticeable and potentially harmful nonetheless. and then what might be solutions. So like there's an increase in like personal cooling devices. Do we need to just like give people a little like the fan and the water bottle in summer? Does everybody just need to have one of those, right? If you're vulnerable to like changes in temperature.
我太不舒服了。你知道，这本身就是一种认知负荷。这是一个分心的事情。因此，我的研究方向很大程度上转向了这种不太极端但明显且可能仍然有害的温度变化，然后可能有什么解决方案。比如个人冷却设备的增加。我们是不是只需要在夏天给人们一个小风扇和一个水瓶？是不是每个人都需要有这样一个东西，对吧？如果你对温度变化很脆弱。
But even like if it's not, if you're at a level that's not dangerous, can we be teaching people a little bit better have like just emotion regulate, right? Is that actually a viable solution where we're not talking about dangerous heat? And so that's kind of where I think my research is headed, but I think there's there's too many questions. And it's going to take a village of scientists to really kind of understand how do we how do we cope with, you know, all the mental health effects of a changing climate. And Dr. Norris-Sarma, what questions do you want to answer? Yes. And I just want to say that I couldn't agree more with the last part of what Dr. Madenbar said, which is that there are so many questions. All of them are really vitally important in order to make.
但即使不是，如果你处于一个并不危险的水平，我们是否可以更好地教导人们进行情绪调节，对吧？这实际上是一个可行的解决方案吗，当我们谈论的不是危险的高温时？所以这就是我认为我的研究的发展方向，但我认为有太多问题了。这将需要一个科学家的村庄来真正理解我们如何应对气候变化带来的所有心理健康影响。诺里斯-萨尔马博士，你想回答什么问题？是的。我只想说，我非常同意马登鲍尔博士最后所说的一部分，那就是有太多问题了。所有这些对于确保
sure that communities are more resilient, more well adapted, can cope with the summertime temperatures that we're going to be facing. Because, you know, even if we immediately address the climatic changes that we're seeing in terms of the different regulations that would be required to do so to meet some of these lower overall temperature change thresholds that we've been talking about, we would still experience some version of climate change for the next few decades while things go back to normal. So it's really crucial to make sure that we have these resilient strategies and adaptation strategies in place. So my own research is really focused on leveraging all of these different big data resources
社区更具韧性、适应能力更好、能够应对我们将要面临的夏季气温至关重要。因为，你知道，即使我们立即解决我们所看到的气候变化，就所需的各种法规而言，以达到我们一直在讨论的这些较低的整体温度变化阈值，在我们恢复正常状态的未来几十年里，我们仍然会经历某种形式的气候变化。因此，确保我们拥有这些具有韧性的战略和适应战略落实到位至关重要。所以我的研究真正专注于利用所有这些不同的大数据资源
to try and understand the impacts of extreme heat and other climate-related extreme weather on mental health outcomes in different communities and populations. I'm really interested in understanding who is most vulnerable and how we can protect those vulnerable populations. So the previous work that I've done that we've talked about has been focused on people with commercial insurance, but I'm really interested across the U.S. and people who are on public insurance, people who don't have access to health insurance, potential vulnerability among people experiencing homelessness, and how that might
来试图了解极端高温和其他与气候相关的极端天气对不同社区和人群心理健康结果的影响。我真的很想了解谁最脆弱，以及我们如何保护这些脆弱人群。因此，我们之前讨论过的前期工作一直集中在拥有商业保险的人身上，但我对全美范围内拥有公共保险的人、没有医疗保险的人、无家可归者中潜在的脆弱性，以及这如何可能
lead to elevated risks for mental health. And then also, I'm really interested in clinicians as potentially on the front line of trying to reduce the adverse mental health impacts of extreme heat exposure. So a lot of my upcoming work is talking with clinicians who are working with patients in different settings, emergency department settings across Boston, hopefully expanding that to look at clinicians who are working across the U.S. at this intersection of environmental risk factors and mental health outcomes to see what they're observing among their patients, what are the patterns that they're seeing, what are the potential points of intervention upstream from visiting an emergency department? So can we find who is the most vulnerable and give them some of the
导致心理健康风险上升非常感兴趣。然后我也对临床医生作为试图减少极端高温暴露带来的不良心理健康影响的一线人员非常感兴趣。因此，我即将开展的大量工作是与在波士顿各地不同环境中（急诊室环境）与患者合作的临床医生进行交流，希望将其扩大到研究全美各地处于环境风险因素和心理健康结果交叉点的临床医生，看看他们在患者身上观察到了什么，他们看到的模式是什么，在访问急诊室之前的潜在干预点是什么？所以我们能否找到最脆弱的人并给他们一些
tools that they need to protect themselves before they need to go to the emergency room? And so, development of those types of relationships in order to partner with the folks who are providing care along the spectrum, I think is really important. Well, I want to thank you both for joining me today. This has been really interesting, and thanks for the important research and work that you are doing. Thank you. Thank you.
他们保护自己所需的工具，在他们需要去急诊室之前？因此，为了与沿途提供护理的人员合作而发展这些类型关系，我认为非常重要。好的，我想感谢你们两位今天加入我。这真的非常有趣，感谢你们所做的重要研究和工作。谢谢。谢谢。
It's been great. Thank you so much. I'm really happy that this conversation is happening and looking forward to all of the continued work to be done. And if you'd like to learn more about this topic, check out the article how heat affects the mind in the June issue of APA's magazine, Monitor on Psychology. Go to www.apa.org backslash monitor. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.
这太棒了。非常感谢。我真的很高兴这次对话能够发生，并期待未来继续开展所有工作。如果您想了解更多关于这个主题的信息，请查看美国心理学会杂志《心理学观察》（Monitor on Psychology）六月刊中的文章《热量如何影响大脑》。请访问 www.apa.org 斜杠 monitor。您可以在我们的网站 www. 上找到往期的《心理学之声》节目
www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills.
www.speakingofpsychology.org，或者在苹果、Spotify、YouTube 或任何您获取播客的地方收听。如果您喜欢我们节目的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评价。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以通过电子邮件联系我们：Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学之声》由李·温纳曼制作。谢谢收听。我是金·米尔斯，代表美国心理学会。
Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery shopping this week. We start with only the freshest items, then review your list and carefully choose each one. Then we pack it all up and deliver it in as little as 30 minutes, so you can feel confident it's what you're. you ordered. Fresh groceries, your way, with Ralph's delivery and pickup. And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery or pickup order. Ralph's, fresh for everyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
放松身心，让拉尔夫配送服务来处理您本周的杂货采购。我们从最新鲜的商品开始，然后审查您的清单并仔细挑选每一件。接着我们将所有商品打包，并在短短 30 分钟内送达，让您确信这就是您所订购的。新鲜杂货，随您所愿，尽在拉尔夫配送与自提服务。现在，您的第一笔配送或自提订单可以节省 20 美元。拉尔夫，为每个人带来新鲜。此剧集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。